mais quoi qu'il en soit eric zemmour
rebat les cartes d'une campagne qui se
lancent étoiles filantes ou hypothèse
crédible il donne en tout cas du fil à
retordre aux partis traditionnels qu'ils
obligent parfois à revoir leur stratégie
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire arnaud
benedetti vous est ce également
spécialiste du décryptage de la
communication politique bonsoir alexis
bigo sur ce plateau éditorialistes rt
france bonsoir alexis et enfin benjamin
cauchy conseiller en communication et
prochain d'eric zemmour bonsoir et merci
à tous les trois d'être là je ne suis
pas chambouler essaye de se convaincre
de nous convaincre marine le pen ce
matin il refusait de le nommer jusqu'à
l'âme alors maintenant elle appelle eric
et surtout elle l'appelle à sortir du
bois et à enfin se déclarer benjamin
cauchy vous le proche d'eric zemmour est
ce que c'est pour bientôt cette
déclaration de candidature croit en tout
cas que s'il a envie d'y aller on n'a
jamais été aussi proche une fois que
j'ai dit ça je les ai rien dit en tout
état de cause ce n'est pas madame le pen
de déterminer calendrier d'eric zemmour
a aujourd'hui il est vous savez dans une
dans une phase de réflexion
à la rencontre des à la rencontre des
français il fait des conférences
littéraires il fit des déplacements avec
des chefs d'entreprise il va visiter des
usines mon bref il en train de prendre
le pouls pour savoir s'il a vraiment ou
pas y aller donc je sais que tout le
monde le pied d'impatience à savoir
quand est-ce qu'ils passent décidé mais
bon ça il faut raison garder et il faut
raison garder c'est pas parce que les
sondages le donnent à 17% aujourd'hui
qui était un très beau résultat qui va
déclencher une candidature immédiatement
sas murine candidature à la mairie
manifestement arnaud benedetti
d'ailleurs eric zemmour il le dit lui
même il y est il l'a dit sur rtl il ya
trois semaines c'est mon intérêt de
faire durer l'ambiguïté quand on crée du
suspense évidemment on crée du désir
c'est bien connu désir qui risquerait de
s'effilocher au au moment de de cette
déclaration
oui cette femme ou rénover désir d'une
certaine manière la réalité c'est qu'en
fait le conti ils essayent de maîtriser
sa communication dans le but de créer
des conditions justement d'un élan et
d'un appel
d'une partie de la droite en sa faveur
sa communication de ce point de vue là
est assez bien rodée elle est assez
habile il crée vous l'avez dit du
suspense il crée un intérêt il suscite
une attention et il en profite surtout
pour bouleverser les deux blocs d
électorat de droite que son l'électorat
de droite des républicains et
l'électorat de droite du rassemblement
national parce que toute la stratégie
des examens aujourd'hui c'est finalement
de décloisonner c'est deux offres
politiques et de les réunir autour de sa
candidature
il profite en plus diffuser des
tergiversations qui sont celles des
républicains qui pour l'instant ne sont
pas sortis de leurs problèmes de
procédure pour désigner un candidat même
si formellement le congrès aujourd'hui
des républicains doivent se tenir le
gros lot 4 décembre doc il a tout
intérêt sur un plan tactique à ce stade
finalement de poursuivre cette cette
forme d'engagement à travers notamment
des conférences qu'il donne au tour de
survivants alors c'est vrai que alexis
poulain
xavier bertrand ne s'y est pas trompé il
exhorte la droite à se rassembler en fin
et à et a décidé en attendant en
entendant lui eric zemmour se dit le
candidat de la droite celle du rpr des
années 80 c
vous le voyez comme ça vous eric zemmour
non on peut difficilement le voir comme
ça ou alors faut vraiment remonter très
loin au premier discours de jacques
chirac à voir comment il a été radical
lorsqu'il a fait fonder le rpr mais eux
c'est le top enfin on en 2021 par contre
là où eric zemmour a raison c'est qu'à
l'époque du rpr il y avait un centre
droit qui existait il y avait ces deux
droites irréconciliables et donc ce que
veut faire un examen aujourd'hui c'est
tout simplement revenir à cet état de
fait c'est-à-dire exploser ce bloc 1
l'ump d'abord et puis les lr ensuite
parce qu'il n'a plus de raison d'être
quand vous avez d'un côté le maire de
nice qui avoue maintenant ouvertement
être un support des manuels mâcon et de
l'autre côté eric ciotti a voisin du
maire de nice qui dit donc moi je
voterai et moore deuxième tour comment
voulez vous que ces deux personnes
soient dans le même parti donc
aujourd'hui l'ump comme l air a vécu
alors c'est un parti qui vit encore qui
va c'est essayer d'exister avec le
congrès mais même le timing de ce
congrès décembre c'est beaucoup trop
tard quel champion va sortir du chapeau
valérie pécresse d'un côté xavier
bertrand de l'autre et puis les autres
on ne sait pas vraiment eric zemmour
arrive et là il fait accélérer le temps
politique en disant simplement ça suffit
l'hypocrisie ce suffit de faire semblant
il est temps de trouver votre camp à
droite alors ça peut faire perdre la
droite évidemment et ça peut profiter
avec le lagon qui va devenir le nouveau
pôle de droite centriste les gens vont
aller vers lui d'ailleurs edouard
philippe lançon partie samedi c'est pas
pour rien c'est pour compte et poussé le
modem un peu plus loin et être un peu le
pilier de cette fameuse maison commune
qui va donner à emmanuel macron le socle
de droite pour être le candidat de la
droite centriste alors à propos de la
droite regardez cette couverture du
telegraph le journal britannique va
s'afficher à l'écran dans quelques
secondes
clairement ils révolutionnent la droite
eric zemmour benjamin cauchy c'est votre
opinion aussi oui je pense qu'il est en
train de mettre un bon coup de pied dans
la fourmilière en train de renverser sur
la table comme dirait le président de
harrods pour cela la référence de cette
bonne série netflix plus sérieusement il
en train de parler à a2 électorat et
monsieur benedetti visé justement on
voit bien que 31 % des gens qui ont voté
le pen en 2017 seraient prêts à voter
eric zemmour dimanche prochain est
exactement cette même proportion de 31 %
des républicains qui souhaiteraient voté
pour pour eric zemmour donc il reprend
effectivement les fondamentaux du rpr il
parle d'un choc des civilisations ils
parlent à la raison des gens et non pas
à l'émotion des gens certains disent
qu'ils flattent les peurs au contraire
je pense qu'il parle à la raison et on
tombe loin de là de de toute cette
émotion habituel des politiques qui
veulent nous faire pleurer sur des
situations catastrophiques pour
distiller des idées progressistes mais
pour le coup eric zemmour il parle avec
quand même une pointe de conservatisme
mais relativement ouvert le
conservatisme ça ne pas dire on s'arrête
le conservatisme ça veut dire on avance
doucement donc il en train de mettre un
point un point d'ancrage sur le choc des
civilisations il en train d'attirer des
gens de partout donc oui il révolutionne
la droite parce que pour une fois la
droite va retrouver une colonne
vertébrale idéologique qu'elle a perdue
depuis de nombreuses années et puis la
deuxième chose je l'espère en tout cas
nous l'espérons s'assoit l'électrochoc
organique et réorganiser la droite
puisque vous l'avez dit tous
effectivement elle explose façon puzzle
à renens vd des tites accord avec ce
diagnostic que fait benjamin cauchy
parce que elle est allée au delà de la
gauche et de la droite cette hausse y
est le candidat antisystème qui est
peut-être justement dans dans l'air du
temps non mais clairement aujourd'hui si
vous voulez il existe depuis da certaine
d'aller un rocher que l'on peut
qualifier d'anti système dont eric
zemmour profite et incarne parce que il
a pour lui à la fois une forme de
radicalité dans l'expression dans l'est
dans les propos et il a pour lui la
cohérence de cette radicalité dans la
durée parce que le diagnostic qu'il fait
sur l'état de la société en fait c'était
un diagnostic qui date de plusieurs
années
quasiment depuis la parution de son
livre le suicide français en 2013 ou
donc il y là il a fait cohérent c'est
cette intériorité il le crédibilise et
ce qui le crédibilise aussi c'est que
finalement
il y a du côté du rassemblement national
qui amène constitue malgré tout quand on
regarde les études d'opinion sa zone de
chalandise électorale principal pour
l'instant même s'il prend je suis
d'accord une partie des républicains
notamment des anciens électeurs le
sioniste mais il se trouve que du côté
du rassemblement national marine le pen
avec sa politique de dédiabolisation a
ouvert un espace politique et l espace
politique et a occupé par son père qui
aujourd'hui est à découvert et dans
lequel évidemment eric zemmour au puise
abondamment à la fois sur le plan
lexical mais également sur le plan des
certain nombre de propositions alexis
paulin pas en vous eric zemmour un
candidat crédible ou finalement
quelqu'un qui comme moi sont définis
d'ailleurs
pardonnez moi et comme il se définit
lui-même quelqu'un finalement de
visionnaire mais qui peut-être n'apporte
pas toujours des solutions concrètes en
une candidature à la présidentielle
s'est beaucoup de guilhem bat bien sûr
il est d'abord polémiste il est pas
encore candidat donc pas de programme
mais ça rappelle quelqu'un vous aviez un
ancien ministre qui se déclarent qu a
pas de partie et qui gagne et il ya la
même mécanique derrière quand j'entends
eric zemmour candidat antisystème quand
on voit le nombre de couvertures de
magazine qui l'a fait la façon dont on
en parle tout le temps dans les médias
il est absolument dans le système il est
poussé par les médias d'ailleurs
certains se demandent si on en fait pas
trop s'il est crédible ça c'est une fois
qu'il sera candidat qu'il va rentrer
dans le débat politique on va voir s'il
est crédible aujourd'hui il se permet
tout il reste polémiste il fait une
campagne marketing phénoménal pour son
livre et il est en campagne en même
temps sans le dire un peu comme emmanuel
macron donc là c'est facile pour lui
c'est maxime sans qu'on vous ait la
faute aux médias justement parce que
c'est une assez des mois qu'on entend
booster ou cette forêt le mois faute aux
médias qui le pousse médias de
milliardaires parce qu'eric zemmour
finalement ils ne dérangent pas vous
avez des candidats déclarés aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne sont jamais testé dans les
sondages qu'ils sont en vie 10 et eric
zemmour il est poussé il est comme sur
un tapis volant parce que'il arrange
emmanuel macron il arrange beaucoup de
gens et finalement il récupère le
travail de longue haleine de long terme
de la famille le pen et sa chance à lui
eric zemmour c'est que ce n'est pas un
héritier il n'est pas un héritier le pen
et en plus comme le dit jean marie le
pen il peut pas être taxé
d'antisémitisme même s'il défend pétain
c'est formidable alors là c'est un cas
molex total de la droite et l'extrême
droite donc oui il a un boulevard mais
parce qu'on le pousse aujourd'hui
personne quand il ya eu un débat avec
jean luc mélenchon c'est le seul qui a
dit allons-y vous avez toute une partie
de la gauche qui alors ne faut surtout
pas débattre avec eric zemmour va alors
quel est l'intérêt vous pouvez ce qu'on
fait et quand est ce qu'on fait de la
politique donc lui aujourd'hui c'est
facile j'attends de voir une fois qu'il
va être candidat benjamin cauchy oui bah
écoutez je sens poindre l'impatience en
vous monsieur poulin j'essaierai même de
vous trouver un tee shirt est fait et
mourra la guerre si vous voulez sur ça
vous irait à merveille
c'est un revêtement honnêtement c'est
peut-être facile tout simplement parce
que il c'est le symptôme du vide comme
disait monsieur sarkozy dans une
interview et quelques jours et que les
républicains que le voyou venir ou non
pardonnez moi les quatre impétrants à la
candidature c'est des républicains
serait ce pas lourd ça pèse pas lourd en
terme de visibilité de notoriété de
ligne politique véritablement porté vélo
gibier salle différenciante et donc ça
pour le coup eric zemmour
c'est facile pour lui parce qu'il n'y a
pas grand monde chez les républicains
parce que marine le pen est quelque part
effectivement perdu entre sept billets
dédiabolisation et puis ses fondamentaux
en revanche
qu'ils soient en campagne ou pas c'est
quand même intéressante et depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est lui qui décide
du thème de la campagne donc il ya deux
choses qu'on va distinguer il
effectivement l'effervescence médiatique
autour de lui qui fait qu'il s'accapare
on va dire du temps d'antenne à ce qu'il
fait vendre aussi un moment donné faut
que les medias monette effectivement les
audiences augmente quand eric zemmour
parle forcément ça fait vendre c'est une
réalité économique il serait malhonnête
de ne pas le cacher en revanche qu'il
n'en voulait pas à l'époque ils vont
continuer son compère de seignosse et
sur la forme et moi je redonne cette
responsabilité à la réflexion aux médias
de réfléchir à cela monsieur c'est le
citoyen qui s'exprime en revanche sur le
fond eric zemmour a quand même réussi à
imposer son thème celui du choc des
civilisations
donc on peut on peut le rail et dire que
c'est facile parce qu'il n'est pas
candidat je te le rail et parce qu'il
fait de l'inter c'est moi le rail et
parce qu'il ya des milliers de jeunes
qui le kilo qui le rejoignent parce
qu'il ya des centaines de contacts par
jour qui viennent dans les amis d'eric
zemmour parce que les femmes avec
zemmour montre qu eric zemmour n'est pas
un vieux sexistes et l'image que
certains gauche on voudrait donner donc
voilà donc non c'est pas si facile que
ça quand les femmes apparaissent le
pouvoir ce dc pour une sortie comme ça
c'était pas la peine quelques sorties
pour le salon qui fait qu il sortait
deux faces du contexte j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un document représente un
petit peu quand on défend la
civilisation judéo-chrétienne et que
l'on souhaite l'égalité entre les hommes
et des femmes je pense que dans d'autres
pays malheureusement vous seriez voilée
pour présenter journal et nous sommes en
france et heureusement les femmes n'ont
pas l'obligation d'être voilée c'est une
défense de la civilisation quand on
défend cette civilisation
judéo-chrétienne on défend l'égalité
hommes femmes on ne peut pas lui faire
ce procès on va se retourner vers arnaud
benedetti a renouvellé tes petits
justement quand on vous entendez ce
petit combat là entre alexis poulin et
benjamin cauchy
justement eric zemmour porté par par ces
médias ou c'est un faux procès
mais je pense qu'il est quand même
fondamentalement très attractif
médiatiquement et ce depuis de très
nombreuses années si vous voulez eric
zemmour il n'apparaît pas depuis six
mois dans le paysage médiatique c'est
quelqu'un qui depuis 20 ans et sur des
plateaux télévision acquis une humilité
médiatique de plus en plus importante et
a construit un discours politique qui
l'a rendu d'une certaine manière audible
audible parce que aussi une partie peut
être de la droite à avais je pense
notamment au rpr abandonner une partie
de ses fondamentaux donc il est à la
fois en effet malgré tout le produit de
l'intérêt des médias il est le produit
de l'intérêt des médias mais il est pour
lui d'intérêt des médias parce que tout
simplement et clairement franceville et
un plateau de télévision et bien fort et
d'audience c'est une réalité et en
politique sa croupe outils en effet la
clé c'est vrai pourquoi fait-il les
vacances merci il passe est vital que
les français au regret de siph parce que
il a un discours qui a été abandonné par
une partie de la classe politique
notamment sur la question par exemple
migratoire donc
il occupe un espace que les politiques
eux ont laissé semblement en jachère et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il fait
d'autres il fait de l'audience comme
jean marie le pen faisait de l'audience
dans les années 80 il faut se souvenir
que jean marie le pen était considéré à
la fois comme le diable mais en même
temps comme un excellent client pour les
médias mais on a un phénomène avec eric
zemmour sauf que entre temps trente
années se sont passées trente années de
vie publique quand années de vie
politique et trente années de fractal
isation et de balkanisation de la
société française c'est sa doudou les
scores dans les sondages et le fait que
maintenant parce que on a ce camp
centriste de la bien pensante de
européiste aussi où on doit aplatir
absolument tout la culture française
n'existait pas pour la limonade macro
ont quand même le président de la
république qui d'une chose pareille
évidemment que c'étaient des blessures
pour les français et donc il est le seul
à le dire il a eu en plus toute latitude
en étant polémiste pour le dire avec
véhémence maintenant candidat moi je
crains qu'il ne soit obligé de revenir
sur quelques déclarations il a déjà fait
sur l'art migration par exemple lors du
débat lundi soir dont je n'ai jamais
dire migration or il l'a dit plusieurs
fois et donc là il risque de perdre un
peu de cette attractivité du polémiste
parce que oui ça peut marcher tant qu'on
n'est pas politique et qu'on doit pas
faire ce consensus pour essayer de
rassembler large mais aujourd'hui c'est
le vide qui remplit à partir du moment
où il va commencer à voir des gens qui
viennent de la droite de l'extrême
droite peut-être d'ailleurs qui vont
commencer à dire ah mais si on faisait
quelque chose ça va être différent non
je pense qu'il va remplir encore plus
pour votre expression il remplit rempli
j'aime pas trop l'image mais
non soit évidemment ça c'est plutôt
symptomatique et comme quoi c'est pas
qu'une bulle médiatique justement pour
faire un parallèle avec un sujet
précédent aucune bulle numérique avec
des digital soldiers des trolls comme
comme on dit maintenant qui serait en
charge de faire monter subrepticement
eric zemmour non il ya une réalité il ya
une lame de fond il ya une présence
militante ce que le disais juste avant
donc soyez raison ce militant qui
représente quoi précisément parce que en
attendant on relève n'est pas candidat
on l'a dit les 500 parrainages c'est
vrai qu'on n'en parle jamais mais c'est
peut-être aussi à un sujet sur you un
appareil derrière de campagne qu'il
faudra le journal se lancera ce qu'il
est prêt de ce point de vue là en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
l'association des amis d'eric zemmour
est une association qui reçoit des
centaines de contacts au quotidien et
que effectivement dans chaque
département dans des camps tomberez
circonscriptions les gens se réunissent
cette association déficit de dons dans
qu'elle peut leur permettre de le
renvoyer des affiches donc il ya une
communication qui est fait sur le
terrain il ya une communication
numérique qui existent également disons
que le bateau amiral attend son
capitaine tout simplement mais ce bateau
amiral se construira en temps et en
heure en tout cas tout le monde s'y
prépare et ce qui est à ce qui est
vraiment
particulière c'est pas pour faire langue
de bois ou quoi que ce soit mais je je
je regarde cette campagne parce que je
suis proche d'eric zemmour et que je
partage quelques unes de ses idées
messieurs je dis je la regarde aussi je
l'observent si vous voulez et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir tous ces
primes aux militants et que ce soit chez
génération z ou même chez des gens
beaucoup plus âgée à venir de nos âges
respectifs sur sur ce plateau
mais monsieur benedetti dans la même
tranche d'âge que nous évidemment ce
sont des gens qui n'avaient jamais
milité pour beaucoup mais moi ça me fait
donc exactement c'est un chirac ah non
ça me fait passer ses chasses emmanuel
macron c'est tout à fait à la face
cachée nyan win alma dans la discipline
a dit c'est l'argent de la différence
c'est que c'est que de partir en cr x et
y sorti de nulle part une ferveur de
vivre ensemble sauf que l'on met du
fonds schirrhein dit c'était quelqu'un
qui avait un parti diriger vers une
carrière politique c'est ça n'aurait
chantal au gendre idéal mais en tout cas
il va partir lundi c'est l'antithèse
c'est la némésis nouvelle macro celui
mais par contre toute la dynamique que
ce soit sur le financement de la
campagne que ce soit sur l'amour des
médias qui lui que lui portent les
médias j'ai en face de mes yeux en tant
qu analyste politique à peu près les
mêmes ressorts que ce qui a été derrière
et me lève macron en 2010 écoutes avec
en plus pour les politiquement ils sont
assez d'accord au niveau économique sur
le fait qu'il va falloir allonger l'âge
de la retraite que de toute façon peut
pas monter les salaires qu'il va falloir
faire un plan d'austérité à partir de
1000 jeunes de tous âges voilà c'est non
non là c'est non à l'otan par gc
pardonnez moi parce qu'on y est il faut
pas exclure c'est le choc c'est qu'il
faut réformer le poulailler ces jeunes
effectivement se succéder sur les
plateaux les ami d'eric zemmour qui sont
parfois très très jeune ça ça vous
évoque quoi ça peut peut-être je suis
assez d'accord avec alexis poulat sur
les ressorts en tout cas de la
communication il y a des similarités
entre la façon dont aujourd'hui se
construit la campagne ou la pré campagne
d'eric zemmour et la façon dont la
campagne de les manuels macron sentence
et s'est elle aussi construite c'est à
dire en effet une très grande attention
médiatique
l'arrivée 2 on essaie de gens qui pour
la plupart n'ont parfois jamais eu
d'engagement politique où on va mais
milite et donc il ya aussi il ya aussi
cela avec néanmoins quand même une
différence a semble-t-il c'est que
emmanuel manuel louis emmanuel macron
pardon pouvait se prévaloir du renfort
d'un certain nombre de leaders d'opinion
ou notamment de grands élus qui d'emblée
l'on suit je pense à gérard collomb à
l'époque au maire de montpellier
de ce point de vue quand même eric
zemmour pour l'instant
me il me dit de me paraît être démuni
que ne l'était emmanuel macro à l'époque
même si je les avais une explication
simple là c'est assez identique en rien
une explication simple arnott tout
simplement c'est parce qu'il n'a jamais
fait de politique intra muros si je peux
exprimé ainsi il n'a jamais été membre
d'un cabinet ministériel il n'a jamais
errer sur les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale donc évidemment il ya des
accointances qui sont moins visibles
pour autant ça fait 30 ans qu'il
travaille aux côtés de la classe
politique en étant journaliste
je suis persuadé je n'ai pas de boule de
cristal ni de scoop à vous donner mais
il est évident que lorsque des instituts
de sondage donnent eric zemmour à 17% je
peux vous assurer que chez les
républicains on le regarde avec beaucoup
plus de respect qu'il ya trois jours
donc il est fort à parier que ces
soutiens plutôt discret pour l'instant
et je j'aime bien parler de tous ces
grands ténors des républicains qui
brillent par leur absence de commentaire
sur le congrès à laurent wauquiez qui
quand même 20 pesé lourd si jamais ils
annoncent un ralliement à eric zemmour
va écouter chaque chose en son temps sur
le voile à chaque chose en son temps
mais je vous ennuie se rappeler une
chose c'est que aussi bon en défense
d'eric zemmour c'est que lui utilise pas
l'argent public pour faire sa pré
campagne parce qu emmanuel macron alors
qu'il était à bercy utiliser les frais
de bouche du ministère pour faire des
déjeuners et des dîners
magazine qui font leur père combien nous
a coûté ces trois jours à marseille
j'aimerais bien savoir et puis avant ça
l'alerté qui avait volé pour cette
affaire bien sûr un petit modèle fin
peut-être avez des dating où le petit
mot défend vous entendez we love et le
petit mot de la fin c'est que en fin de
compte aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation quoique il faut quand même
rester très prudent moi c'est ce que je
pense qu'en effet il ya une dynamique
qu'il faut regarder de près qu'ils nous
ont envahis ne un potentiel est
aujourd'hui non négligeable sur
l'ensemble des droites françaises mais
qu' il faut rappeler qu on est à six
mois de l'élection que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les sondages ne font pas
l'élection que les estimations font fait
il faut le rappeler aussi pour un
certain nombre de sondages sur ceux qui
sont sûrs d'aller voter et qui c'est qui
nous disent qu'ils sont sûrs d'aller
voter dont
une table ces sondages os x lion soyons
prudent je pense c'est ce qui me paraît
en tout cas là la principale leçon qu'il
faut tirer de cette séquence
effectivement merci à nos benedetti avec
six poules à benjamin cauchy méfiez-vous
d'avoir été en direct avec nous ce soir